oh I guess that means it's time or at
least nearly time people are still
fighting in Tal just mentioned the cause
of this slide I have started since
Caribbean dev conf last October where I
did a whole talk where I originally
wanted to just have nothing up at all on
the screen and the organizers are we
can't have nothing do you want your
profile and picture uh player is like
that's the worst thing that could
possibly be up there where you just put
be kind as sort of a theme for the talk
and I thought sure what I want to have
that before at the start and end of
every talk I do now at least ones that
I'm doing sort of on my own
when I'm co-presenting it's kind of a
more awkward to get it in there so I've
got a different bit of white on every
slide that I have like this but I figure
I could hopefully move the industry a
bit in terms of yo understanding of
c-sharp and understanding of versioning
today and dates and times but actually
if I can move people just a little bit
to be a tiny bit kinder and I'm sure
you're all lovely people already but if
just being prompted makes you do one
more act of kindness then that possibly
has more impact on the world than
anything else I can do so that's why I'm
doing it okay however we're really
talking about versioning today because
I'm still on a quest to find a topic
that I can submit and still get accepted
but that no one shows up to
I've tried dates and times I thought
most people would think those are pretty
boring but people still came I've tried
versioning and you're all still here
this afternoon with Jennifer we're
trying feminism you know if I can't bore
people away maybe I can scare people
away but please do come it'll be great
but I seem to be drawn to topics that I
find fascinating and many other people
don't so we're talking about versioning
or maybe we're talking about hobby
really how many of you know her Nobby a
few okay her Nobby is a game of trust
and communication it's a collaborative
game I'm not going to go into all the
rules and things but you're you
trying to build something together and
you can see each other's pieces but not
your own and you can give tiny tiny
limited information and you have to
trust that everyone else is we're all
working to the same goals and the reason
I mentioned this is I learnt an RB a few
weeks ago at code mash and it only
struck me sort of ten minutes before
giving this presentation for the first
time that her Nabi and versioning are
intimately linked okay
versioning is a game of trust and
communication I have a very small amount
of information I can put in a version
number at least you
I could put version 2.1 point 0 - the
one where i fixed the bug that does this
but it's still preview because but I
don't think anyone would use that so if
we're using normal version numbers we
have a very limited amount of
information but we have to trust each
other that we're not going to screw each
other over so that sort of goes back to
the be kind as well we are all in this
collaboratively if you try to play
versioning in a competitive way it's not
going to work out well for anyone so I
want to think somewhat high level at
least for most of the talk out of
interest how many of you are dotnet
developers ok good right that means I
have to speak relatively quickly so that
I can talk about the diamond dependency
problem in dotnet specifically but we're
not just going to talk about one kind of
version so we're going to think about
why we have versions at all how they're
very very contextual a bit about
compatibility and all the joy of that we
will wonder after a while you know how
many of you came this morning thinking
how is the world not collapsed yet ok a
few of you hopefully as you leave you're
all be going how how is it all working
it's a little bit like when you look at
a bicycle and think that's a very
vertical thing and you're saying I need
to just keep it vertical the whole time
that's never going to work
and somehow this seems to have been the
case for versioning in net and I'm going
to hopefully put forward some ways of
improving things so starting with why we
have versioning at all
I mentioned communication and versions
are pretty much always some form of
communication representing almost a
contract between different parties who
those parties are can vary immensely but
there you're trying to give information
about something else
through this version and the something
else can be multiple different things so
we usually if you start saying version
people often think libraries because
that's sort of the things that we
consume and produce most that the
versions change the most but Mads and I
were talking yesterday about c-sharp 8
and referring back to things that were
introduced in c-sharp seven and 7.1 and
seven point two and thinking about
c-sharp nine so clearly languages can be
versioned and platforms can be versioned
I'll show you some of some of the dotnet
related version numbers at the moment
books can be versioned which is a very
nice segue to say the fourth edition of
c-sharp in depth is kind of hitting the
printer's really really soon but I'm
communicating something in that in that
sense that if you've got the third
edition the fourth edition is going to
be different because it's not got the
same version number if I said the fourth
edition was coming out and you bought it
and it was exactly the same as the third
edition you would feel treated cheated
you would have trusted me on something
and I would have misled you you see what
I mean that it is all about trust and
trying to communicate something these
are all to do with change so broadly if
something doesn't need to ever change it
doesn't need to be versioned you could
give it version one and it will always
be version one and that's kind of boring
so just don't bother so evolution is
clearly going to be part of why we have
versioning at all
and in general the the aspects of how
code can evolve and how all the aspects
of code the the many things that go
together by the time you've got
something running how those can all
evolve in parallel is something that we
don't think about enough in general and
versioning is just one aspect of that
and all of this is important because the
point of versioning within computing is
generally so that we can have some kind
of predictability some kind of trust
that if I smush together all of these 15
different things with 15 different
versions they will work because I know
that a different set of versions of the
same things worked and people have told
me whether it's through semantic
versioning or something else that you
given this set of versions works this
slightly different set of versions
should work so I've talked about
versions a lot what do we know about
versions we've actually got a fair
amount of common ground here that we
haven't we don't tend to put into words
so versions are almost always textual I
can't remember seeing any version that
wasn't some form of text and usually in
my experience and this may well be
different around the world it's usually
ASCII and it may or may not be human
memorable so as an example of something
that you could argue is actually binary
rather than text take a git hash that is
a version of the code base or the
repository it doesn't need to be code
that's a way of identifying this is what
was in the repository at that point and
we happen to see it as a hash that's all
in hex so it is textual and ASCII but
you could argue that's actually a binary
version it's the the hashes raw bytes
versions may or may not be a form of
identity and in many cases this is
absolutely desirable
so libraries if you download no to time
and I'll refer to no to time many times
it is not to what to get you all to
start using it because I'm sure you're
all using it already but it's just a
handy thing to have a concrete example
if you download Notre time 1.2.3 which
is now years old today and then you
download 1.2.3 tomorrow you absolutely
expect them to be exactly the same if
you talk to an API as in a Web API some
kind of web service and it says I am
version 1 of this API do you expect it
to be exactly the same if you hit
version 1 tomorrow can it return more
data can it accept more fields we'll
talk a little bit about that later on
but the point is that the context
matters and that identity isn't always
as simple as it sounds
we've said that there usually text and
in one particular case they're often
numbers and a sequence of numbers so
semantic versioning in particular gives
us a partial ordering and it's only
partial so if I say which comes first
one point one point zero or one point
two point zero it's pretty obvious which
of those was released first if I ask you
which was released first out of one
point one point one and one point two
point one who knows so it is only
partial and you shouldn't infer more
than you can if I give you a git commit
commit hash if I give you two of those
which comes first it doesn't provide
enough context in itself you need to go
to another system
git will be able to show you when each
of them was committed and maybe one is
an ancestor of the other maybe they are
sort of siblings and don't have a common
ancestor at all or sorry neither is a
common ancestor of the other
so there are all these aspects of
versions that we may have just taken for
granted before I haven't told you
anything new yet I suspect and I may
well not do so for most of this talk and
that's fine I can still achieve my goal
without you learning anything new
because my goal is that you think about
versioning more okay there are also
potential for aliases like I'm not a
Linux hardcore person but I gather that
Debbie and 9 is also called stretch and
I know there are various other aliases
in various other flavors of Linux and
there can also be marketing names like
Visual Studio 2017 was Visual Studio 15
and Visual Studio 2019 is Visual Studio
16 and whereas as time is advancing
faster than the version number we're
okay when it was sort of Visual Studio
13 was in 2012 I think or maybe that was
vs 2013 they were a little bit close
together and easy to confuse but that's
the difference between a marketing name
and the the version number that we would
use for anything where we want to be
kind of reliable and then you've got
marketing names that end up being really
confusing like Java 6 versus Java 1.6
and goodness knows what's going on there
so I've said about some confusing
version numbers here are some more so
this is when I put together the slide
this slide and I'll probably never
update it because it doesn't really
matter how current it is but this was
current at one particular time so we had
dotnet the desktop framework for point
7.2 and lots of numbers for dotnet core
so you download an SDK that was to point
to point 200 that provided to point to
point 1 is the runtime and that runtime
implements dotnet standard 2.0
and that sdk has the version of the
compiler Rozlyn or the Microsoft's eShop
compiler implementation Rozlyn that
supports c-sharp 7.3 and if you've
installed Visual Studio 2017 and the
current version that was 15.9 then that
will work well with all of this so when
I say that we need to know how versions
work together as well as how they evolve
independently this is the sort of thing
I'm talking about and here we've got
several different versioning schemes
within just one slide talking about one
family of products the.net core SDK
version number is particularly
interesting because of the way that
Microsoft has sort of decided to have
its sort of four numbers rather than
three so there could be a two point two
point 201 which you could sort of think
of as two point two point two point one
and there's a document explaining why
they're doing that and what everything
means and that's a really good thing and
it doesn't matter too much to me at
least that it's not a very familiar
versioning scheme if you read the
documentation you will know what it
means you will be able to make
predictions about what will be in a
particular version compared with other
versions another example of the same
sort of thing the being deliberate about
version numbers is this business about
dotnet standard 2.0 I was in a
conference call after several emails
around what we should call the next
version of.net standard that's the
version that will ship with dotnet core
3.0 and be supported by 3.0 and not be
supported by dotnet core 2.0 2.1 or 2.2
I haven't yet heard about the dotnet
core 2.3 it could happen who knows so we
considered dotnet standard 3.0 dotnet
standard 2019 dotnet standard a dotnet
standard 2.1 thought net standard 2.5
and we looked at the pros and cons of
each of these and I was in this
conference call for an hour and had
previously responded on emails but this
was actually the culmination of a lot of
work that Kathleen dollar and Mo and
lots of people have been doing to try to
work out all these pros and cons and I
offer this to you as a model of Industry
doing it right possibly coming to a
different conclusion than you would have
come to because it's kind of
counterintuitive that net core 2.1
doesn't support net standard 2.1 when
you know it was true for dotnet called
2.0 supported dotnet standard 2.0 but
part of the reason for choosing 2.1 run
3.0 is to break that tie within
developers minds and the sooner we do
that the better if we have dotnet core
3.0 supports dotnet standard 3.0 then if
you haven't already got the idea that
those are tied together you would
probably get the idea and then when
things change later on maybe in five
years time dotnet core won't be the
primary implementation of dotnet
standard there may be some may be a
company that one of you will start will
come up with a completely new
implementation and that will be
absolutely fine and this sort of goes
back to all Scott's demos earlier on so
we don't want it to be tied to dotnet
core so we break people's mental model
as early as we can and all of this is a
great example of people actually taking
the time to think and taking the time to
say what am i communicating where am i
if I've got to break trust with people
because they've assumed things that
maybe they shouldn't have assumed anyway
but do because we're human what can we
do so in some ways this is the key slide
as the key example of what I want all of
you to do which is go away and anything
that you are versioning think about how
your
it and the impact let's go back to
thinking about context so I've mentioned
some things that can be versioned
already books and all of the things on
the previous slides applications office
can be versioned operating systems can
be versioned languages platforms
libraries protocols many levels so yeah
we've got HTTP two layered on top of
I've no idea does anyone happen to know
whether TCP and tcp/ip have versions
beyond you know we know the address
versions we're mostly still on for even
though we should have moved to six but
are there separate versions of IP that
evolve over time as well I honestly
don't know but all of these certainly
can be you know we we know about pop3
imap4 etc and things that are built on
top of those protocols so where you have
API so the the Google Cloud Storage API
currently on version one as far as I'm
aware and at some point maybe there'll
be a version two built on top of other
protocols with their own versions and
beyond things that are published we work
with versions every day within source
control you know what is the current
version what what's the last commit of a
particular file or even a particular
resource you know this particular slide
deck I did in PowerPoint the one this
afternoon Jennifer and I will be
presenting we've done in Google slides
and it has a version history so that's
versioned as well and when you're
designing a versioning scheme
you must not assume that the versioning
scheme you've used successfully for many
things in the past applies to things in
the future that are different so for
example you know Mads is here designing
c-sharp 9 if math said Jo what everyone
in dotnet uses semantic versioning
therefore if I'm building c-sharp 9 I
can break everyone's code it's fine we
don't make any process that promises
about backward compatibility we could
steal classes by default yeah it doesn't
work you've got to know the context
because that will change who's using
these versions and what you're trying to
communicate with them and the impact of
breaking things you also need to know
how your dependencies so I've mostly
been talking about the versions that we
publish but the reverse is true as well
I mentioned that there's a doc
explaining the SDK version where a doc
explaining net standard versioning and I
don't know whether as doc explaining
c-sharp versioning but mostly it's all
backward compatible so it's kind of okay
but you need to understand what people
are trying to tell you when they publish
versions and know that that won't always
mean the same thing for exactly the same
reason is you need to think of a new
versioning scheme each time here it can
be an existing one but you need to
reconsider it each time you're doing
something in a different context every
time you're consuming things from
different contexts you need to ask what
people are telling you so let's give in
to one particular versioning scheme this
is probably amongst ourselves the most
well understood
semantic versioning and we'll think
particularly in the context of libraries
and probably for the remaining 38
minutes we'll talk about libraries for a
while and their network API s-- for a
while and these are just two examples
that but they're probably the ones that
affect most of us the most
so semantic versioning we have a major
number a minor number and a patch number
and we can have something saying it's a
pre-release and it's interesting that
there are multiple ways of showing a
pre-release because this is a ga version
if it were zero point two point three
that would be a pre-release
if it's one point two point three - beta
one
that's a pre-release I'm not sure
whether it's really a good idea to have
zero point something means something
differently yeah what version should I
use before the first release of one I'll
use zero point something what version
number should I use before the release
of two I'll use I can't use one I'll use
two point zero point zero beta 1 and we
have inconsistencies but yeah it's
backwardly compatible with what people
have been doing in a somewhat at hoc way
for years and years and years so to
teach all of your grandmother's to suck
eggs so to speak if you make a breaking
change you bump the major version number
if you make a non-breaking change that
is backward compatible you bump the
minor version number and if you make a
change that is backward and forward
compatible you bump the patch number now
what do I mean by backward and forward
compatible I tend to think of what can I
safely do if I'm consuming a library if
I am currently if I have code that I
believe is okay using 1.1.1 then I can
safely move to one point two point three
and everything should still work because
it's backward compatible one point two
point three will say is ordered later
than one point one point one even if
they didn't come out chronologically
that way
and so that should be fine the reverse
is not true
I cannot go from one point two point
three back to one point one point one
and expect that my code will still build
or execute if you're in an environment
that doesn't have a separate build step
because maybe there's a new feature in
one point two that wasn't in one point
one my code uses it so if I try to
downgrade to one point one bang that's
fine that's not the case for patches
that should be backward and forward
compatible if I'm using one point two
point three I should be able to go back
to one point two point two everything
should still build if you're in a build
kind of environment and the only changes
you know there must be some reason for
having a new version number
there must be something changed but it
can only be implementation details so
there can be some kind of bug that I
fixed or that the library provider has
fixed rather and I might see that change
so it's reasonable for my application to
start failing because it turned out I
was relying on something that was fixed
in 1.2.3 but it should definitely still
build and nothing else should have
changed now there's a problem in
everything I've just described does
anyone want to venture a guess as to
what I'm going on to next Oh either
you're all shy or haven't thought about
this quite enough is I've talked about
compatibility and not breaking people
and I don't think we really understand
what that means we sort of think we do
um I've kind of explained it that if I
have code that builds against 1.1.1 it
should still build against 1.2.3 or
let's just be simpler one point one code
builds should build in one point two
let's forget about the patch things what
does that mean I can do let's stick with
c-sharp for the moment what can I do
between one point one and one point two
if I'm creating no design one point two
what can I do that's going to be
compatible at a class nope not if I'm
going to be really strict about this I
assert that I could you know playing
devil's advocate as a as a user I could
create an application that builds
against one point one and then you add a
class and my code no longer net no
longer builds because maybe I've got a
class with the same name as the one that
you've added and I've got using
directives for both namespaces and
suddenly things are ambiguous okay so
that's a fairly big new way of doing
features as how
what else might I be able to do that
slightly smaller yeah optional
parameters what about optional premises
adding a new parameter so to an existing
method I've got one method that's foo
and it takes int X and you're saying I
can change that from foo int X to foo
int x equals x in y equals zero right
you've skipped on two slides in fact
because that so to some extent that is
source compatible it's definitely not
binary compatible if someone has built
code so say I have built my application
that relies on foo int X and I've got
that executable already built and then I
just plunk one-point-two DLL over the
top and try to run it it'll say well no
I was expecting something new optional
parameters are a compile time thing I
was expecting to find a method with one
parameter there is no such method
anymore bang okay maybe you say that's
fine I will make it just i'll only care
about source compatibility which you may
well only compare about care about
source compatibility and this is where
context matters again I'll come back to
that in a sec when I finished this
example but even source compatibility
isn't enough there because suppose I
have a method accepting an action of int
previously I could have done a method
group conversion of that method from the
library and passed that as an argument
to the the method that accepts an action
of it I can't do that when I've got only
a method with two parameters so maybe
you say I'll do overloading instead I'll
keep my foo that takes an int and add a
foo that takes an int X int Y and that
sounds good that gets round that
particular problem it then causes
another problem if you try to do a
methyl group conversion and
there are two methods one accepts action
int and what accept action int int and
now you've got an ambiguous overload
resolution problem so I contend that
almost anything and math suggested
something yesterday that may just about
work but I suspect I can break it
because I usually can I contend that any
public API change you make could break
someone if they tried hard enough to be
broken okay and yeah if if you were to
give some cast iron guarantee no I will
pay you five million pounds if if you
are broken by this upgrade well then
it's going to be quite easy for someone
to claim that five million pounds adding
a method well I had an extension method
that was being called before and now
it's not and Matt is claiming that
adding a property might be safe so at
some point it's on my stack to traitor
oh no reflection I I think it's
reasonable to ignore reflection if you
are using reflection and peeking up my
private fields then you know if I were
if I were writing this I I claim that I
won't break anyone I would definitely
put something in saying reflection
doesn't count because that really is
what's intended to be an implementation
detail so many of you I'm sure you some
oh sorry is that another thing that
might be a if you have another method
with the same name as the property that
was added that's exactly what I'll be
trying and depending on the lookup rules
apparently there's cunning things to
change that depending on whether you're
trying to invoke things but if the
property is itself a delegate type that
could be invoked then I think it'll get
weird as I keep saying my life is full
of corner cases I'm sure I'll find one
somewhere and so that means if we were
to be really strict about semantic
versioning we would only have
at one point oh and one point 0.1 and
one point 0.2 we can do patches but we
could never have another minor version
does that sound like a the world that
you want to live in
no because taking a new major version is
a big deal you are saying trust me it
might break this is a scary thing you
probably don't want to do it unless you
really really have to expect some pain
so instead we're in a situation where we
know that something we have treated as
black or white as a boolean toggle no is
this binary compatible is this source
compatible really isn't and that's the
first thing that I think we should be
trying to change as an industry and it
will be very definitely language
sensitive it could well be that in Java
or in JavaScript or some other language
that there are all kinds of non breaking
changes and there could be a bunch of
theoretically breaking changes that no
one's actually going to worry about but
I think we should do better if we start
caring about versioning more we will do
better in terms of tooling and say okay
I'm going to I want to publish this as
one point one point oh is it actually
compatible according to my rules that
could then be machine consumable in some
way both at your producer side saying I
want to check it and then anyone else
can see right what standards are you
holding yourself up to in terms of
compatibility
that's one simple example where we were
talking about a single library what
happens if that library has dependencies
what happens if that library wants to
take a new dependency hands up those who
think so say no to time notice time may
indeed start to take your dependency on
Microsoft dot dot X tensions or
abstractions or whatever it is okay
hands up those of you who think that I
can do that in a patch version no one
hands up those of you who think I can do
it in a minor version just a couple and
major version ok most out of people who
voted major version was the biggest one
right I would probably go with major in
that case would it make any difference
if this was actually a brand-new library
that no one else could have had
dependencies on it's a gray area and
we'll get into why that is in a bit
suppose I have a dependency on Microsoft
extensions logging version I have no
idea what version it's actually at but
suppose I've got a dependency on 1.2 and
I want to upgrade that dependency to one
point two point one can I do that in a
patch bump of no time minor bumper no
time and does that require a major bump
of node assignment ok roughly equal and
people didn't want to commit which is
absolutely fine I would say patch in
that case I'm sort of propagating the
the trust that I have in the Microsoft
folks saying oh we haven't actually
broken the public API here so I'm saying
well I haven't broken the public API I
exposed transitively what about if I
take a new minor version of Microsoft
abstractions logging is that a patch
version no I'm seeing a few nodes in a
few hands is it a minor version yes and
is it a major version
a couple and of course the answer is
there's no single right answer here I
would tend to aside from anything else
because it's really easy to remember say
if you're taking a new major version you
bump your major version if you're taking
a new minor version you bump your mind
version if you're taking a patch you
bump your patch and taking a new
dependency is effectively going from
version zero to version whatever it is
that you accept so that would typically
be a major version if you're taking a
new dependency on a library that you are
producing yeah that's really tricky
because you've got a workout
and this is a thought process that we go
through in my team producing the dotnet
client libraries for Google cloud
platform services we go through a
thought experiment of right if I do this
in a particular way who could it break
and you can imagine again just like with
the the c-sharp specific code examples
you can imagine I have this customer who
adopts this set of versions and then
they update to my new version do they
get broken or not and if they get broken
then maybe I should bump it up by a
major version but it ends up getting
silly so suppose I'm suppose I have a
new off library within the Google API so
and this is something that we're
considering and this is absolutely a
concrete example slightly simplified but
concrete example so we have a GAC's
library which is common Google API
extensions we're at 2.5 of gacks
we would like to introduce a new off
library to get rid of our old off
library dependencies that end up
depending on a bunch of stuff we don't
want to depend on so I will create a
Google dot off for the sake of
convenience 1.0 in the new version of
gaxx
you know by what I've said before it
should be gapps 3.0 that takes
dependency on Google auth 1.0 but
actually who could possibly be broken by
an
dependency on a library that didn't
exist well in theory in several years
time we might have a Google door off 2.0
and people could have been depending on
a really old version of gaxx cax 2.5 and
google door off 2.0 and so updating to
GAX 2.6 that depends on off 1.0 could
break them or break dax break their
dependency on gax because gaxx 2.6
depends on something in 1.0 that's
broken in 2.0 i don't think that's going
to happen though i think anyone who
takes a far distant future dependency on
earth is living in the far distant
future and wouldn't have a really old
dependency on GAX and i realized that
having a slide with actual concrete
examples might have made this easier to
follow but you're all very smart people
so we've said that when we do that
eventually that's just gonna be a minor
boot boost because we thought about it
and we have considered these cases and
we're acting in good faith and we know
that people are trusting us and
hopefully that they'll be able to get in
touch if things go wrong I mentioned
contexts earlier on and how that affects
you how you version thing X depends upon
on what thing X is and that a library is
different to a language there's more to
context than that because there's
knowing how the thing is going to be
used so if you are writing a library how
many of you write libraries that are
only used within your own company lots
right now at Google we build from head
as in if I commit a change to a library
everyone starts using that next time
they build and that means I can do
something without we often don't have
explicit versioning it's just well
Pinder this particular commit number
effectively things were working means I
can do something I would never dream of
doing a node a time between major
in a major version I can remove a method
shock because I can see all the code
that could possibly call it it's like it
was all internal within one assembly in
c-sharp and that's an awesome situation
to be in and it sounds like many of you
are in that at which point maybe you
don't care about the binary
compatibility things because you know
that people aren't going to ship a
binary that was built against a
different version of your library yeah
maybe because that then depends on
dependencies if everything that ship is
that shipped is built at the same time
then you're in a good state but this
business about binary compatibility the
idea of code that was built against one
point 1.0 will it work against one point
2.0 and that it doesn't work for the
optional parameter version I'm not
picking on you it's it's just a really
convenient example thank you for giving
it that's really important because we
can have multiple dependencies and
complex apps do have multiple
dependencies so suppose your application
depends on library X that depends on no
design 1.1 and it depends on library Y
that depends on notice I'm 1.2 when that
application is deployed
notice I'm 1.2 is going to be deployed
with it so library X that was built
against 1.1 is going to end up having to
work against 1.2 and that should be ok
if I've done my job properly as notice
I'm maintainer I'm looking for binary
and source compatibility so that should
be fine and then this happens hopefully
you can still read that near the back
it's the exact same example as I gave
before just now except instead of 1.1
and 1.2 we've got one point two and
three point two and there is no reason
to believe that this should work
okay with current build tools as far as
I'm aware and please if I'm spouting
nonsense tell me well feel free to say
say now but as far as I'm aware with
current project formats and whatever in
in.net you will end up running
everything against a single version of
libs II which is version 3.2 and you
have to hope that lib X still works
maybe it will maybe it won't that's one
way we can get into Diamond dependencies
and here's a slightly different one book
with exactly the same result it's
slightly simpler I depend on a library
that depends on something else Lib Zed
and it depends on an early version and
my application directly depends on libs
e3 point - now I've said there is no
reason that this should work how many of
you are running any kind of net website
okay chances are you're all in this
situation or rather probably the
previous situation because as soon as
insurv libs ed I say Jason net do you
want to look at all your dependencies
and what they're transitive dependencies
are and reckon that they're all using
the same major version of Jason net I
don't think so so we're lucky that
although I trust that James has been
diligent and actually has only bumped
the major version of Jason net when he's
needed to I suspect that even the
braking changes aren't very braking what
version of Jason dot let's react now is
it thirteen twelve thirteen something
like that imagine in version fifteen say
James Newton King thinks oh yeah we've
got Newton soft Jason no one calls it
Newton soft Jason maybe I'll move
everything into a namespace of Jason net
okay I can do that in version fifteen
it's it's a new major semantic version
that really would cause
everything to fail now I know there are
all kinds of interesting plans with
dotnet core having its own lightweight
jason reader and things but i would
contend that the fact that things are
still working is more through
coincidence and probably pressure on
james to keep things compatible than on
good engineering so i think we need to
try to fix this i believe there are ways
of doing it but it will require language
changes and probably nougat changes and
maybe course ALR changes although i
don't think so certainly the desktop
framework was quite capable of loading
two different versions of the same
assembly at the same time yay it's just
that there's no way of building a
project file so that you'll end up
deploying two different versions of the
same assembly at the same time it's
possible that if you had them both in
the GAC and you had strongly named
dependencies with the full version
number you would end up getting multiple
versions but maybe you want to do this
so that this situation works that liv-ex
ends up using an entirely isolated copy
of the version that it expected rather
than the application using 3.2 now there
are two situations for Lib X here one is
that it's using Lib Z
purely as an implementation detail yeah
maybe it's parsing it's Jason
configuration file and populating some
objects and that's fine or maybe it's
something like no de time dot
serialization Jason net which is
deliberately designed to work with Jason
net and you can pass it adjacent
settings or adjacent sterilizer settings
and it will configure it to work nicely
with the node a time types you the the
public API is intertwined with the Jason
net API those are different situations
that we cannot tell apart at the moment
so I think when we express a dependency
we need to be able to say I want this to
effectively be
I'm part of my transient API transitive
API sorry very different or I want this
to be a private implementation detail
and then in c-sharp nine when we have
the idea of references that are private
or public we can say alright okay
compiler you should give me an error if
I have any method accepting or returning
something that is from a private
implementation detail yeah that's that's
not allowed and that would let us reason
about things much better and remember
that we're all about trust and
communication and reasoning about what
will work based on this very limited
information even with what I'm proposing
which I do expect to write a blog post
about at some point we don't necessarily
end up with goodness because suppose
Libs ed has some kind of static cache
that we expect to work that we expect if
we call please get me the ID for you
know some name and it will generate an
idea if it needs to and always return
the same thing well if we can load the
two separate assemblies that's fine
except we've now got two caches that
maybe we're expecting to only get one oh
and the other language feature that we
may need in c-sharp as well as stopping
us from doing things is allowing us to
do things we've got external EEOC's
already that say oh i want to refer to
this assembly we need some way of
getting in the project system saying i
depend on both of these these are both
public dependencies so they're part of
you know maybe this is not--it only
serialization jason net and this is some
other maybe not date and time but some
geographic thing and it's integration
with jason net and they both exposed
json settings and i need to be able to
pass things around and from app 1.0 i
need to be able to say oh i'm referring
to the json net 1.2 or jason net 3.2 so
we need some better integration of what
I'm talking about with relation to all
my depend
sieze so there are issues there but I
think if we start thinking about
versioning you may have caught a little
theme there then we can actually achieve
an awful lot more I'm going to close
with an example of how things can be
very different from the library
perspective and I was planning when I
prepared the slides originally I was
planning on saying this is how Google
does API versioning already at that
point it was a forward-looking statement
I have a we have an API improvement
proposal thing internally where we can
write up standards effectively and then
get them reviewed and what I'm going to
describe is what what I have been
proposing and then in fact while I was
away at another conference
a bunch of people thought sure what we
want to actually do it quite differently
so I don't know in two weeks time
whether this is going to work or
something else will work but it's it's a
valid proposal I'm explicitly not saying
that this is what you ought to be doing
for API versioning because you need to
think about all kinds of people many
many different people there the number
of stakeholders for versioning of a
networked API is huge you need to think
about the people who are going to use it
your end users and hopefully that will
be the largest set of stakeholders and
probably the ones most sensitive to
Peyton then you've got the people
building the api's you you may within
your company have ten different API s
and you're the poor chump who's
responsible for designing this version
strategy that all of the others are
going to have to abide by so you better
make it easy for them to evolve their
API as they go forward you probably want
to make it so that they can evolve it
and test an idea with a certain set of
end-users before they commit to it maybe
you've got some infrastructure that
needs to support this version and you've
got people like me who
client libraries to make it easier for
the end-users and they'll need to
understand the versioning to and
certainly in our case in Google you've
got API reviewers who need to be able to
see are you were doing this in the
previous version you're doing this in
the new version that's not a backward
compatible change just as I said that we
need the idea of rules of well this is
compatible and this isn't compatible in
a language so it is with an API you may
think suppose you're just calling a JSON
API to return the weather and you
currently return it in Celsius so you
return a JSON object with temperature :
no one you may think it's fine to start
saying Joe I'm going to start returning
it in Fahrenheit as well but in a
completely backward compatible way I
will do another property called
Fahrenheit and that will be you know
whatever it it's 33 I don't know and
then some user start complaining because
they're trying to consume this response
on an Arduino and your response is now
bigger than it was before and it's
crashed their machine because it hasn't
got enough memory but you need to decide
does that mean you can never ever add
any fields to your API that's probably
not what you want to say but you want to
do this deliberately so you need to
think of all your stakeholders in Google
we describe our API is in protocol
buffers which are basically schemas
effectively schemas and then
descriptions of our pcs and they look a
bit like this I know I had a bug last
time I gave this talking I don't know
whether I fix it now but so we have a
service that's got an RPC that takes a
request then gets a keyring and the
request has a single field that's a name
and you get the idea so what kind of
versions will be come up with for this
do we need the idea of minor version and
this will depend on your API
within Google I'm just gonna skip some
slides because we're running short on
time within Google this is our current
proposal that we have the idea of an
experimental API version that can be
broken at any time so the API producer
team might decide to just take the
endpoint down and please I see people
taking photos only take photos hey this
is something I might consider don't
assume this is actually what Google does
or is going to do so experimental is
unstable really unstable it might exist
but you know give you completely
different responses tomorrow we've got
an alpha version which is under debate
should that be stable or unstable if it
has to be stable then it's harder to
change okay because maybe we've got
maybe in version 1 of version v1 alpha 1
you have an RPC and you have a way of
representing errors and you say oh I'll
just return a string and then you want a
bit more information so you would like
to change the type of that field to be
an error message it's unfortunately the
protobuf declaration for a data type is
called message so when I say an error
message I mean message error that
probably has a string field called
message and detail and things so can I
change a field that was previously of
type string to one called error
definitely not in a compatible way so if
I'm doing this at an alpha level maybe
we'll say that doesn't necessarily need
to be stable when it comes to beta they
tend to be public and maybe we can't
communicate with our stakeholders as
much our end users because we haven't
done it as an opt-in thing anyone can
just hit this API it's harder to
communicate we don't have consent to
email everyone maybe so we're more
likely to make things stable and then
you really do need to do multiple
versions of the ape
and you probably need to keep these up
for longer so if you've got a service
implementing if you've got an endpoint
implementing V 1 B 2 and V 1 B 2 sorry V
1 B 2 1 and V 1 B 2 you probably need to
keep both of those up in parallel for
longer but eventually you get to V 1
woohoo you ship glorious victory parties
all around and then you want to add a
new feature and this is where I have
been sticking to my guns possibly to my
colleagues annoyance various colleagues
want to be able to say oh we'll just go
back to beta 2 V 1 beta 2 I'm saying no
that sounds like it comes before V 1 you
something beta 1 always comes before
that something you've shipped V 1 you're
doing a new thing to some extent so
we've got this idea of V 1 you can read
this as V 1 point 1 alpha 1 V 1 point 1
beta 1 but the key is there's no V 1
point 1 ever the only GA general
availability version of the API is just
the major version because accepting you
know the the the version numbers here
end up within namespaces and all kinds
of things and we want to be able to just
upgrade things seamlessly and people
will get more or less information
depending on what they happen to expect
so if you build against V 1 with an old
version of a client library you'll only
see some fields that you get back maybe
the fields will have come across the
network but you won't have the code to
access them but you can just update to a
later client library version of the API
version v1 I don't think I have a slide
but we deliberately made the decision
our client libraries have the API
version number is part of the nougat
package name so Google Cloud storage v1
which means if we ever do have Google
Cloud storage v2 you can have both of
those packages you can depend on both of
them and migrate some of you
code and then the rest of your code and
it should be wonderful but this business
about new features get wrapped into v1
is entirely different I would never do
that in no time I can't release 1.0.0
again ever so there's no sense of
identity this is one scheme you may want
a sense of identity you might want to
say okay well I've got two ideas of
version number the sort of the the major
that describes the end point and
everything generated uses that but you
could also specify maybe a date field or
some way of saying the API at this point
so that then your Arduino people can say
I would like your API to behave as it
did at this point in time and your
server can then say alright well I
wasn't populating Fahrenheit back then
I'll stop they all remove it from my
canonical response but you've got to
have infrastructure to do that so you
need to balance the the extra work that
the infrastructure team need to do and
how do you test do you test all of your
requests against all of your possible
versions every time you deploy and by
the time you deploy it a thousand times
and you have a hundred tests you're now
running a hundred thousand tests every
time may not be feasible that was
probably somewhat confusing which was
almost intentional because the whole
point was not for you to learn
Google's versioning scheme but to learn
that it's complicated that there are
lots of decisions to make with lots of
different variables of about here how
much time does the infrastructure team
have is it actually you're in a small
company and you're just trying to get
api's out so whatever's the most simple
will work because otherwise you will run
out of money and just the company will
collapse it's all complicated we are
really bad at several things in software
Jennifer was talking about accessibility
earlier on we're awful at error handling
in general we're awful at anything that
requires understanding other human
beings which is why diver
one of the many reasons diversity is
important but virtually is one thing I
hope I've persuaded you today to spend a
bit of time consciously thinking about
and documenting why you make the
decisions that you make about any
versions that you produce and finally
and it's sort of the same point be kind
to anyone who's using your code whether
that's colleagues and users whoever it
is thank you very much
[Applause]